if you weren't a chemist what would you
be
I don't know I think I would like to be
in a band but I not play any instruments
so that's probably not gonna happen
Oh blimey what would I have been I think
I might have been a hi-fi salesman or
run a shop
cuz I'll always enjoyed music I'm not
good at making music sadly Oh
Rockstar that'd be great Prime Minister
no I don't know I think chemistry is all
right I'll settle with it I might be a
musician of a professional cook I'd work
in a museum I'd work somewhere where I
could you know again it's still like
here where you'd meet different people
every day you could explain things to
them I don't know I would probably be a
particle physicist instead I always
quite like that as well although when I
was about five I really wanted to be an
archaeologist about a paleontologist
actually I was obsessed with Dinosaurs
so maybe maybe if I maybe five-year-old
meat would still be a paleontologist but
I love music and I used to work in a
hi-fi shop part time when I was a
student I've installed hi-fi's and some
very famous people's houses I won't
mention some very nice high fives and I
love the experience of sitting down and
really listening to music really
intensely you'll tell me off-camera who
the famous people about yeah well maybe
if you weren't a chemist
what would you be a physicist
I ask you another question if you
weren't a scientist what would you be
depressed I really not sure though on
one of my other videos I said that I
would really quite like to make TV
adverts and in some ways our videos are
a bit like TV adverts for chemistry